hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question for
one of my four meters GT who asked what
is my top marketing priority for the
year so GT my interview would be I'm
focusing a lot of my time and marketing
on social media now when i first started
my business I kind of hid behind my
content we did profiles the famous
entrepreneurs and their success stories
and people would right in saying well
you're Evan Carmichael the websites Ivan
chronicle com who's Evan Carmichael and
they were starting to ask about me want
to learn more about me and my personal
brand and my story so i bought a little
bit more of that on the site but one of
my goals on going is to be able to
connect with my fans more to answer more
questions that people are writing in
asking questions I'm really curious to
help them grow their business if I can
through these kind of videos and other
means so a great way to do that is
through social media so it's a great way
to kind of connect with my customers see
what they're up to see how it can help
and try to provide a lot of value on
going I think it's going to be a super
important part of of my personal brand
and also the success of the website and
the success of all the entrepreneurs
that are trying to grow their business
so I hope that helps GT I'm curious to
know what your top marketing now
applying is for the year and everybody
else I'll to hear what you're up to if
you want to leave a comment on the video
please share your thoughts and also
always appreciate thumbs up if you want
to leave one under this video thank you
so much for those it always gives me
energy when I see people have left
comments and give a thumbs up so thank
you and stay tuned for the next episode
you